es ist wirklich Wahnsinn so eine Stimmung
einmal Weihnachten das Träumen wir uns doch
alle oder das ist mal so herzlich dazu geht
herzlich willkommen jetzt hier noch mal in
Ruhe zu Puffers Happy Hour wir sind heute sehr
andächtig hier beisammen zusammengetreten mir
ist was aufgefallen ich weiß nicht ob Ihnen das
auch schon mal aufgefallen ist ihm schon mal
aufgefallen alles ist irgendwie schlecht alles
ist irgendwie also irgendwann also selbst es
fängt vielleicht mal gut an aber irgendwann ist
es dann auch schlecht wie zum Beispiel Atomkraft
ist es jetzt schlecht ne oder ist schlecht ne
Rasen auf der Autobahn ist schlecht ne wenn das
sogar sehr schlecht aber selbst Angelina Jolies
Brüste sind ja mittlerweile schlecht und da muss
man sagen wenn doch alles irgendwann schlecht ist
bedeutet das ja das eigentlich alles schlecht ist
verstehen Sie also man sagt zwar immer in Maßen
ist alles gut aber selbst das ist ja in Massen
schlecht also so ein Süßigkeiten z.B in Sneakers
am Tag ist in Ordnung ja aber spätestens nach dem
dritten Topf Nutella zum Frühstück da sagt auch
die beste Pumpe pass mal auf ich mache jetzt in
Vertretung das wird mir hier zu viel verstehen
also dicke sind potentielle Tote ist einfach
so nein ach ist doch nicht schlimm dünne auch ne
ja nur nicht so früh also so muss man das sehen
ja oder rauchen zum Beispiel Rauchen wir sind ja
rauchen ist schlecht ne es gibt doch keinen der da
draußen jetzt noch rumrennen ne nach der zweiten
Packung kippen immer noch denkt so das war jetzt
aber genug Sport für heute oder also gibt's
noch so an sie wissen rauchen ist tödlich ja
selbst Wasserpfeife also dieser Obstsalat unter
den krebserregern es ist nicht gesund auch ohne
Filter es hat keinen Sinn wir lernen wenn es quant
ist es schlecht okay sie stellen sich auch nicht
mit dem Pilz vom brennendes Haus ja neben TV
Zug und denken Sie dann das aber gut für die
Atemwege ne machen Sie nicht auch wenn Opa eine
ohne verbrannt wird sagen sie nicht ja das wird
jetzt ihren gesundheitsstrip es ist schlecht okay
fertig gut früher war auch noch gut ne da hat man
gedacht Mensch ja das kommt ungefähr hin da wusste
man aber noch nicht dass die Krankenkassen auch
nicht schlecht nein also die Krankenkassenbeiträge
die Steuereinnahmen übersteigen seitdem man das
weiß weiß man rauchen ist schlecht nur rauchen ist
mittlerweile super schlecht ich weiß wie früher
haben sie ja noch drin rauchen können mittlerweile
müssen sie auch raus ne und dann stehen sie im
Winter bei minus 20 Grad T-Shirt von der Kneipe
ja hey man sich innerhalb von zwei Minuten
diesen Glimmstengel rein das macht ja auch keinen
Spaß also Sie haben ja mittlerweile Probleme an
Lungenkrebs zu sterben die Lungenentzündung rafft
sie ja früher hin ne also wirklich gut man hat uns
diese wärme-inseln gebaut diese diese Heizpilze
wo so die Fontanelle auf 360 Grad angewärmt wird
aber man muss auch diese Heizpilz haben verboten
werden also selbst die sind schlecht also man
kann sagen rauchen ist im Grunde genommen
dreifach tödlich okay also entweder Lungenkrebs
Lungenentzündung oder Heizpilz also ist es
wirklich schlimm ja wobei auch noch weitergeht
ich meine versuchen Sie mal unter so ein Heizpilz
also ich meine wenn sie da stehen und rauchen sie
haben war im Kopf aber der Füße die sind ja geil
wie in so einer Tiefkühltruhe also wissen Sie wie
sich messen das Füße auf dem Mount Everest
angefühlt haben ne ich mache mein Handstand
unter dem heizbild weil ich denke das ist ein
bisschen warme Füße nur ist auch schwierig also
ich meine machen Sie mal in der Zigarette
in der Linken Pilz in der rechten Handstand
unter dem Hals bin also mein Arme begegnen
sie da ja keinem auf Augenhöhe wenn Sie ein
Gespräch führen wollen ich war und ehrlich gesagt
kriegen sie auch nicht hin also wenn Sie mit dem
Pilz und eine Zigarette in Handstand hinkriegen
sollten Sie sich sofort bei Wetten das bewerben
wobei auch das mittlerweile tödlich ist also
man muss sagen das ist wirklich also brauchen
ist vierfach tödlich wirklich ist krass und
jetzt sind sie auch noch beim Alkohol dran ne
haben sie es mitgekriegt Alkohol soll jetzt
auch wieder verboten werden ganz schlimm ich
komme aus Köln und da wollen sie jetzt Alkohol
also so Flaschen in der Öffentlichkeit mit 40 €
Strafe belegen also dass sie nicht mehr draußen
unter freiem Himmel schön einen Weg tanken ja
also im Grunde genommen hat es wirklich also
wir können nichts mehr machen das heißt wir
Deutschen hätten ein Problem mit Alkohol aber
mal ganz ehrlich wir haben kein Problem also
war wirklich Beschaffung und Konsum passieren auf
dem höchsten Niveau das muss man doch auch einfach
mal feststellen das Ausland wirklich beneidet
uns doch darum ne wie wir damit umgehen die
Bild-Zeitung hat das sehr schön festgestellt die
Bilder hat gesagt immer mehr besoffene es reicht
es könnte ja auch nicht reichen aber nein
es reicht also sie haben mich gar nicht
verstanden also muss man schon mal sehen man
muss aber nein aber alles ist ja immer schlecht
wann begreifen wir eigentlich dass vielleicht
die Regierung auch schlecht für uns ist ja das
können wir noch mal feststellen oder es heißt
wenn man man muss den Bürger beschützen ja
aber wir beschützen uns eigentlich vor
denen das machen wir ja nicht dann ich
meine Demokratie steht doch immer so ein
bisschen für Freiheit freiheit heißt auch
dass man mal so ein bisschen unvernünftig sein
darf was habe ich denn noch für eine Freiheit
ne ich darf sitzen das war's oder stehen mir
darf sie ehrlich denken Sie daran wir haben
dieses Jahr wieder Wahl also zünden Sie sich
ein Wahllokal an ja trinken Sie dabei schön
ein Bild und Rauchen sich zwei Packungen gibt mir
in die Birne das ist eine Form von Freiheit Prost
ZDF hat einen Namen Qualität
also das ZDF heißt ZDF und da
ist Qualität und wenn sie ZDF
oder 3sat ist auch also öffentlich-rechtlich
abonnieren